New York Democratic socialists AOC
leveling bombshell allegations on
conditions at migrant detention centers
after she joined a group of House
Democrats who visited two detention
facilities in Texas yesterday
the congresswoman even reportedly
screaming at border agents at one stop
here are the explosive claims she's
making about the treatment of those
migrants there's this was them on their
best behavior and they put them in a
room with no running water and these
women were being told by CBP officers to
drink out of the toilet they were
drinking water out of the toilet and
that was them knowing what a
congressional visit was coming that was
this is CBP on their best behavior
telling people to drink out of the
toilet did you see somebody actually do
that order patrol issuing a harsh
rebuttal to the freshman congresswoman
firing back saying the accusations are
not true I can tell you with the utmost
confidence that the migrants anyone and
everyone in our custody at all of our
facilities have ready access to fresh
water they have access to consumer bills
and the standards that we apply to make
sure that on a recurring and very timed
basis that not only they have access to
the types of consumables and fresh water
that they would need I've never heard in
26 years of being in this business ever
heard of that type of allegation being
made Greg do you believe her I would
actually need to see some proof to this
I think it's just her being sneaky
because I don't believe this is my gut
is that there no one's been drinking
from any toilet but if you see that the
water fountain is situated above the
toilet for plumbing reasons and
emergency shelter at often incorrect
asila T's you will see that you'll see
the toilet and then it's the same for
plumbing reasons because that's where
the plumbing comes out of so the water
source is below
it's not toilet water it's actually bath
it's drinking water but it's above the
toilet but she's clever because she just
broadly says they're drinking from the
toilet and and people can go like oh
yeah because the toilets there so I
think that what she did was she said
something that is false but
directionally true like meaning she
could get away with it I do think what I
think the bigger story too is how the
left has this free pass to demonize
anyone we've seen accusations of child
abuse directed at people who work there
she's suggested that these guys white
sexually assault her she doesn't feel
safe around them these are horrible
things to say about people casually to
save them casually but if you respond
angrily or you make a criticize her
suddenly she becomes the victim did
these are snowflakes bearing
switchblades they come at you in the
moment you respond it's like oh my god
you're you hate me and it's like it is
kind of weird in the in the irony of
this whole thing is the left
incentivised it incentivizes these
crisis's by egging on to things the
caravans though they were sent they were
encouraged as a way to overwhelm the
border to create visuals next they were
incentivized to bring children because
we the activists were telling people it
was easier to get across the border if
you bring kids and it's easier to
demonize the people that are meant to
deal with this influx and so the result
is you have more sexual assaults more
drowning and more death I mean these
centers are probably the best relief
that these people are going to get in
this situation and they're being
demonized it's really by the very people
who are incentivizing it and she voted
twice against bills it would have
provided more resources for these
migrants in these facilities and then
she goes down to the facility and say
they're not getting the right resources
looks pretty hypocritical are you
talking to me I am talking because I
think one of the things that happens
here is we can politicize this and I
just would prefer that we not do that
but I will say this that the big news to
me is that have this Facebook page group
Border Patrol agents who have absolutely
spoken and dehumanizing terms about the
mind
and they've also made awful sexual
innuendo about Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
the congresswoman and now we have a DHS
inspector general report in which the
Inspector General Jessie says three of
the five stations have no shower for
children kids have no change of clothes
and no way to do laundry and two of the
station's two of the five have no hot
meals for kids so these are not good
situations and if you then understand
the kind of very hostile rhetoric that
the agents have been taking part in on
the Facebook page then for the
congresswoman to do her duty which is to
go to that station and to inspect it and
to see the conditions and not just
engage in political rhetoric in
Washington but actually go I think she
has a right to feel silly so she did no
political rhetoric down there that
wasn't a photo-op nor when she insulted
those political break I tell you what
was was insulting them talking about her
in look we can we can go into that too
but she called them child abusers and
that's called concentration camps I
think Katie we all agree we want the
best for these migrants we want to take
care of them as best we can give the
situation they should not be here they
should not have come here the way they
came here it's an unfortunate situation
but the Border Patrol agents they're not
trained for this they don't have the
facilities and of the money they're
doing the best they can right well I'm
glad that she made a real trip to a
detention center to a shelter instead of
posing for a photo op in front of a
empty parking lot like she did the first
time around with the photographer and
her fake crying that's the first step
the second thing is that her outrage is
totally fraudulent because she has voted
against every single piece of
legislation that would have at least
eased the situation temporarily the
reason why Juan you're seeing a lack of
facilities a lack of food a lack of
clothing for children is because the
Border Patrol is overwhelmed these
facilities are meant for maybe a
thousand people there are four or five
thousand people who are crowding
abilities and that is happening because
Congress and people like AOC continue to
use this as a political talking point
instead of actually solving the problem
when when Wayfair sold bad
to the Border Patrol to have beds for
children who didn't have them she led a
boycott and said that they shouldn't be
selling beds to children and then she
goes down there and says why don't any
of these children have any beds and so
it's completely disingenuous and the
fact is that this can be fixed and if
you want to be part of the solution then
you don't just go down and call the
Border Patrol sexual assault or sexual
predators and Nazis you actually vote
for things that make it better yeah and
some of the witnesses down there Dana
according to the Washington Examiner
said that she went in started yelling
and screaming at the board of patrol
officers refused a tour of the facility
and misc characterized the conversation
she had with the detaining it is pretty
astonishing that you can have several
people all saying what she said about
drinking water out of the toilet and you
can have several people all saying what
you're just describing here which is
that how inappropriately she was acting
and aggressively in hostile initially
going in and I obviously emotions are
running high one of my favorite
Beatitudes is blessed are the meek who
are the meek the meek are the children
are we responsible for taking care of
the children we are at this point at
this moment and I think what the
administration has figured out is you
have to prepare our way to triage this
situation so one of the things they did
today is of all the immigration fights
they decide we're going to print the
census without the citizenship question
whether make would have won on the
merits I think they probably would have
but there was there were problems with
it it is the executive branch's
responsibility to do the census the
president's going to get that done fine
they take it off the table they just got
the 4.5 billion dollars signed last week
the president signs that into law it's
not even enough money so then they have
to figure out how could they hire more
people to deal with what she's talking
about and then I think the third thing
if you just had if you only got three
wishes
the third thing has to be this asylum
piece and I think that on some of these
must pass pieces of legislation are
coming up in September I would focus all
sorts of resources on figuring out a way
to change that because if they don't I
think what Greg's talking about the
caravans and the visuals and they know
that the administration is under
pressure so they're going to continue to
send people here but you're not going to
happen we are not equipped to take care
of the things
Dana is not about anything that that we
say oh you know where these kids are
being taken care of the incentive is
these people are fleeing oppression and
poverty and they want the better life
for their families and children
everybody could talk about how do you
fix the problem at its source so they
don't want to leave I'm for that in
other countries are should not be
dictating our border policy by sending
people we cannot forget the children are
being used and abused as passkeys into a
country who built that the people in the
United States who mocked this
humanitarian crisis months ago we know
who they are
I think aoc deserves a tip of the hat by
the way for using her just a cure to
shine a light on what's going on and
make I think a lot of people think she's
exploiting the tragedy and then doing
nothing about it legislatively